how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and
everything relating to the marvel
cinematic universe and we just got
one division episode four and it did not
disappoint
now as we knew from an exclusive clip
that marvel gave us literally
hours before wanda vision episode 4 came
out this
episode was from swords perspective and
of course some other main characters as
well such as darcy lewis who is back
from
thor jimmy wu from ant-man and the wasp
who worked for the fbi and was keeping
watch of ant-man scotland himself and
now we have monica rambo working for
sword
and as we got into the episode it was
nice to know that sword really didn't
have a good idea of what was going on
they really didn't know more
than we did as fans but this episode was
very revealing it answered a few
questions but of course as
marvel studios has been great at doing
with one division left us
with more now fast forwarding really
quickly to the end monica rambo said
that it was wanda controlling everything
but i don't believe that to be true and
i'll explain that
in this video i'll do a scene by scene
breakdown explaining all of the really
important details that you need to know
because there are many in this episode
and then at the end i'll talk about a
theory that i think
marvel is really trying to get us big
with misdirection here
and i believe they're really trying to
keep us from knowing what is really
going on
specifically they don't want us to know
who the actual villain is
so let's jump right into it because
there's a lot to break down
so the opening scene starts with monica
rambo and this is not the first time
that we've seen monica rambo in the mcu
she was actually the little girl in
captain marvel the daughter of maria
rambo
and actually if you pay attention very
very closely you can hear some voices in
the very opening scene
as monica rambo's body is kind of coming
back together after being blipped we can
hear
captain marvel call monica rambo when
she was a kid
captain trouble a direct callback to
captain marvel now as the scene goes on
we can tell that monica was actually
snapped and this is the part where she's
coming back after
hulk brought everybody back and it's a
really awesome scene and very different
perspective than we've seen in the mcu
so far
in spider-man far from home everything
kind of seemed
a little bit happy they kind of talked
about everybody coming back a little
light-heartedly they showed people in
spider-man far from home coming back
still being in band uniforms but in this
episode we see how actually it was very
very chaotic and nobody really knew what
was going on at first and everybody was
extremely overwhelmed
monica then sees a doctor that she knows
after roaming through the hall of the
hospital
monica obviously has no idea what has
happened and neither does the doctor as
she
asked where did you go the doctor
clearly knows that she was snapped and
everybody is coming back but has no idea
what happened to them when they were
gone
and according to monica it was just as
if she fell asleep and woke up right
away
unfortunately in this scene the doctor
tells monica that her mother maria rambo
from captain marvel has sadly passed
away
you have to remember that there's a
five-year gap from infinity war when
everybody was snapped to when they came
back in avengers end game
so monica got snapped but her mother
didn't and in that five-year period of
time
unfortunately she died but monica
doesn't really understand that because
she doesn't understand that she was
snapped she doesn't know about the
events that took place and to her
she was only gone for about a second she
was with her mother she fell asleep
woke up and then everything was thrown
into chaos the doctor eventually tells
monica that she disappeared
then we cut to the marvel intro then we
appear in the sword headquarters which
stands for
sentient weapon observation response
division
this is another branch of shield in the
comics they are basically the same thing
as
shield except sword is responsible for
outer space
we see on the screens that everything is
kind of going back to normal the people
who were snapped are coming back
everybody is celebrating the pope's
about to speak monica used to work at
sword and she tries to get through a
door but can't because she has lost her
credentials because she's been dead for
the past five years
director tyler hayward comes and lets
her inside of the door
and as she's walking to the door we see
a picture of her mother on the wall it
reads
maria photon which was her nickname
rambo
we learned that monica is the first of
those who got blipped or snapped to
report in for work
no surprise there not a lot of people
would be too gung-ho to go back to work
after you've been dead for five years we
find out that monica used to be an
astronaut in some way shape or form
and she's been into space at least one
time before however the director says
they don't focus on that anymore
instead now they focus on robotics
nanotech
ai and sentient weapons now this is most
likely due to tony stark
robotics are technically all of the iron
man suits ai was
jarvis and friday his ai that operated
inside the suit and basically operated
everything else with stark industries
nanotech we saw tony stark introduce an
avengers infinity war
and now we are kind of starting to
explore the side of sentient weapons the
director says the world is not the same
now there's a lot of threats in space
in which monica replies there's always
been a lot of threats but also
allies this is referring to captain
marvel we learned that monica's mother
maria was the founder of sword or at
least one of the founders of sword which
makes sense
given the fact that by the end of
captain marvel she had a relationship
with nick fury of shield
captain marvel and the scroll they go
into an office which looks a lot like
the office that nick fury was in
at the end of captain marvel but in the
same building offices often look the
same so it could be a different office
but it does look like nick fury's or
what could have been his before
we know he definitely got a few
promotions since we saw him in captain
marvel
the director tells monica that she is
grounded and can only do terrestrial
missions meaning missions on earth this
is a protocol that her mother put in
place for people who would come back
from the snap
before she died so she's asked to go
help out the fbi with the missing
person's case in jersey
here we meet jimmy wu who was in ant-man
and the wasp working for the fbi still
in charge of watching over ant-man he
introduces himself with a card trick and
if you recall in ant-man of the wasp he
was really fascinated with how scott did
magic and he was trying to learn on his
own it appears that he has learned
agent wu explains that he has a missing
person that he originally
thought ran away but then he says he
contacted the person's relatives and
friends and none of them even know that
he exists
he then says it gets even weirder when
he goes to the cops and he asks them
about westview and they say that the
town of west view doesn't even
exist even though the sign for it is
right behind them now i believe that
this is directly linked to
the villain of the show something has
erased people's memories of
west view but clearly there is a whole
town of west view
wanda didn't just create this town out
of nowhere there's a sign for west view
off of the highway to exit and then they
have a sign
right before you enter the town so
something has come over people
outside of the bubble and inside of the
bubble that makes them forget about west
view and the actual reality of
everything
agent wu then says this is the case of a
missing town not a missing person and
monica asked why he hasn't gone inside
yet
and he says the town doesn't want me to
monica takes a drone which would end up
being the helicopter that we see in
episode 2 and flies it into the energy
field
it disappears from plain sight monika
then goes up to the energy field sticks
her hand in it and it sucks her in
revealing how she got into this
alternate reality that somebody has
apparently created and how she has
become a character
on the one division show we then go to a
scene with darcy lewis who used to work
with jane foster from both
thor movies her and a few other doctors
are being transported to west view in a
van and she asks them all what they do
and they all do very different things
which she says means they have no idea
what's going on
that's why they're bringing in a bunch
of different experts so they can find
out
we then find out that she is now dr
darcy lewis and she's brought into her
workstation and asked to make an
assessment and her assessment is they
are getting a ton
of cmbr cosmic microwave background
radiation
she says that there are longer
wavelengths superimposed over the noise
here
she then busts out a device that allows
her to see inside of the bubble it's
older technology that can pick up on the
wavelengths
now cmbr cosmic microwave background
radiation in real life
is said to be a remnant of the big bang
or the start of the universe
this could have serious implications on
the marvel cinematic universe
but in the older days when they had tvs
like this cosmic radiation was the cause
of static in the old tvs which is most
likely what they're getting at here but
this will most likely come into play in
the future of the marvel cinematic
universe we then see the different
perspective of the beekeeper we see it
from swords and the beekeepers
perspective and they are trying to go
down a sewer drain
under the bubble to try and get in
however it does look like the bubble
doesn't
exactly stop at the ground it does have
a radius that is a full circle or
hexagon as we'll find out
as the sword agent goes in we cut to the
director asking for
some sort of a visual of what is
happening inside of this energy bubble
this is where we find out that darcy has
found a way to watch what exactly is
happening
inside and here's where a very very
important line from darcy comes in where
she says
i know it's been a few crazy years on
this planet
but he's dead right not blipped but
dead obviously referring to vision who
died in avengers infinity war
darcy explains that inside of the cmbr
there was a broadcast frequency that she
picked up with an old television
that's how she's able to watch inside
however she doesn't know much more
outside of that she doesn't know if it's
real time she doesn't know if it's
somehow pre-recorded
she doesn't know why it's a sitcom she
basically knows about as much as we do
as fans
agent wu says so the universe created a
sitcom starring to avengers and darcy
says that it's a working theory and she
really doesn't know how it works
and then it looks like she never got her
coffee which is sad someone needs to get
her some coffee
but it does reveal however that in the
previous episodes when we saw somebody
watching them
it was indeed darcy from here agent wu's
team
starts to try and figure out who exactly
everybody is he says that originally
this case started as a missing person
case which i think
is notable we have no idea who this
missing person is but they were in
witness protection which means they are
somebody
of some sort of a value and although we
have no idea who it is
agent wu does say that it was a hymn and
i do have my theories on who it could be
more on that in just a bit woo says
they've identified two people who are of
course
wanda and vision and it's time to
identify the rest and the team goes to
work
they start identifying people and they
realize that the barrier is actually a
hexagon
now we've been really spotty about the
hexagons so far and we've been asking
why
and agent wu is asking why as well as we
can see on this whiteboard we can see
that the hexagon
barrier has a 5 mile radius and they
don't know why it's a hexagon
now there's many theories surrounding
this right now none of which are
confirmed yet but
some of them are that it's a hexagon
because wanda has cast a hex
or a spell another is that a hexagon has
six sides and 666
is the sign of the devil aka mephisto
who we believe to be the main villain
another is that the hexagon is a symbol
for aim
and somehow they're with hydra and have
something to do with taking over this
town
and wanda again more on that in just a
bit sword starts to find out more
information about more people
inside of this town and one thing that
is definitely worth noting
is the profile of abalash tandon who
plays norm at the very bottom of his
profile we can see that it says
abalash expresses concern for his father
and sister
this information was obtained when
vision awakened him
is wanda controlling a whole town
physical safety of residents
is now in question when vision releases
him
abalash becomes norm again so it appears
that
off screen we didn't see it ourself in
any of the episodes but when vision
comes in contact with avalash or norm as
he's known inside of the bubble
norm awakens and he remembers everything
that happened before he was put in this
bubble but then it says
vision released him and he goes back to
being norm this is going to be
a major factor moving forward in one
division it appears that vision has the
ability to release people from
this spell or this trance whatever is
happening to them but he also has the
ability to put them back in
so is vision alive is he dead but most
importantly
is somebody controlling him now
eventually they find out a lot of
information about a lot of people inside
and eventually darcy does end up seeing
monica rambo on the tv
and here's where a pretty important line
is dropped by agent wu
darcy says that it looks like monica
rambo has to play
undercover she says that it looks like
she has to play along in which agent wu
says
with whom or else what and this is a
really big giveaway
of what could be happening tying into
the last episode
where agnes and herb were saying we are
all and it cut off but we believed that
they were going to say
trapped here darcy then has an idea
about a way to kind of communicate with
wanda and we discovered that it was
agent wu who was trying to communicate
through the radio with wanda in episode
2. now a few major things to note here
as they discover all of these people
inside of the town
they discover agnes but they don't know
who she is
in real life again we believe she is
agatha harkness and there is plenty of
evidence for this but agatha has lived
for centuries and centuries since the
salem witch trials that started
on june 2nd which by the way is what she
says the anniversary date is with her
and ralph but the fact that she's lived
for centuries is most likely
why they can't find anything about her a
person like that probably isn't inside
any databases
as that person probably doesn't want to
be but this fact also means that she
definitely is playing some part of what
is happening
the same goes for dottie they actually
don't have any information on dottie up
at all
not even a picture or her name inside of
the series
but it is very apparent that she is seen
on screen and darcy says she's talking
with a new character
and jimmy wu says a real person which i
don't actually believe to be so
i think she's a villain as randall is
talking to her dottie ends up breaking
the glass
cuts herself but wanda makes that part
skip over
and to the outside looking in it never
happened then we cut back to the sword
agent
going inside of the bubble through the
sewer and as he passes through the
energy bubble he becomes
the beekeeper so it seems like whenever
somebody goes through
this energy field it turns them into
whatever is appropriate for the time
meaning it changes their clothing this
is what happened with monica she went in
with her sword attire on
but her clothes were changed however it
did look like her sword badge was turned
into a sword
necklace so there are still some
remnants of the real life that transfer
over
into this bubble reality they just
change a little bit so the beekeeper
went in with a sword
hazmat suit on but then as he went
through the energy field it turned into
a beekeeper suit
he pops out of the sewer and we see
wanda and vision and wanda says
no but it is a little different than we
heard in episode two
but unfortunately we don't really find
out what happens to the beekeeper
and right now this is one of the bigger
questions that we don't have an answer
to when wanda
alters reality what exactly happens to
other people who are being changed
we then go back to sword who now has
many different tvs looking inside of the
bubble
we are reaching the final scene from the
last episode episode 3 where wanda is
giving birth
and this is where things start to get
really intense monica
inside of the bubble reality says ultron
in which that surprises darcy and agent
jimmy woon they say
has that ever happened before has this
bubble reality ever referenced the
actual reality
they say no and just as wanda is getting
very
very scary more like the scarlet witch
the scene cuts
darcy says somebody is censoring the
broadcast and then they ask where rambo
is in which the alarm goes off because
she just flew back
into the main reality but then we see
what happened from monica's perspective
when she was talking to wanda
wanda is now very very intense and
very scary she asks monica who she is
and she says i'm just a neighbor
wanda replies then how could you know
about ultron it appears that wanda has
sort of broken out of the fake reality
she is in at the moment and is
remembering
the old reality wanda says you're a
stranger and an outsider and we see
her magic come into play which we
haven't really seen much
most of the magic that she's done so far
we haven't seen the red
energy surrounding it she says i think
you should leave and she uses the magic
to get rid of geraldine aka monica and
beau and send her back into the main
reality
but a few things to note here when she
brings out her magic
we can apparently hear something in the
background and we could also
hear this with the energy field it's the
exact same noise and it does
sound like people are talking then after
wanda actually throws her out of the
reality
she is looking at her magic like it's
somewhat new to her or like she did
something that she wasn't really
expecting to do
and this is the main part i want to talk
about in just one second
wanda realizes what she did and she
fixes everything and goes back to her
twin boys
vision then comes in he asked where's
geraldine wanda says oh she left honey
she had to go home in which she turns
around and dead vision is there
scaring the absolute heck out of me it
was literally like a jump scene when i
first watched it
he says what is it what's wrong and
wanda looks up again and he's normal
now what's happening here is wanda is
remembering her actual reality
she remembers vision is actually dead
he's not alive
then one of the most important lines of
the entire series is dropped vision says
we don't have to stay here we can go
wherever we want but then wanda replies
no we can't and she says it in an
extremely creepy way that doesn't really
seem like her
she says this is our home and vision
asks are you sure in a very
concerned manner like he kind of knows
what's going on
wanda then says oh don't worry darling i
have everything under control
we then cut to monica rambo saying it's
wanda
it's all wanda the final scene is of
vision and wanda picking up their twin
boys and one goes well what should we
watch tonight
and if you notice vision has an
extremely concerned
look on his face but then immediately
after he forces a smile
like he's forced to go along with it now
here's what i think is
actually happening the biggest thing to
notice here is that at the end
after wanda uses her powers to get rid
of monica she is a completely different
person
she says we can't leave this is our home
oh darling
i'll take care of everything don't you
worry about it this is not
wanda it doesn't sound anything like her
her voice even changes and she doesn't
call
vision darling she calls him viz or
vision
everything that she does after she uses
her magic on monica is completely
out of character now we know that there
is some kind of a spell put on the
people inside of the bubble and even
some people outside of it and i actually
think
wanda is under that spell as well and
who is responsible for the spell
ag of the harkness and mephisto or
nightmare now obviously this is
something that agatha harkness doesn't
want wanda to know but
other people seem to have figured it out
and this could go back to
vision it appears that when vision has
contact with people
they seem to remember the actual reality
but if you notice
they're all kind of scared and this goes
back to the line of jimmy wu
darcy says they have to play the role
and he says for whom
and if not what what happens what are
the consequences
well it could be that all of these
people are under a spell by mephisto and
agatha and they realize that if they
don't go along with everything they're
going to have to deal with them
vision seems to be somewhat aware of
this at times but i do think that he
is going to end up being the key of
awakening
like the one report said the people in
the town and ultimately
wanda now i do think that she is under a
spell
it's not all wanda yes she does have
some power over this reality because her
herself
is a witch and has very powerful powers
but the second things don't go as
mephisto or whoever is behind this wants
them to go
she has no power just like she was
trying to get rid of the stork in
episode 3
she couldn't get rid of it she can
basically do what she wants as long as
it's in line with what
agatha and mephista want the second it's
not
they correct it they change the reality
this is ultimately what i think is
happening
wanda is being controlled by somebody
but let me know what you think is
happening
in the comments down below do you think
it's wanda or do you think somebody else
is behind it
let me know and be sure to subscribe so
you don't miss out on any of the latest
one division videos don't forget to like
the video and for live updates you can
always follow me on instagram and
twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
me